you know that's what we that's what uh
so we try to do each and every week we
understand it's a huge challenge
um in this league go out there you play
top-notch quarterback tight end
receivers
um we try to go in and just play
complimentary football from offense
defense and special teams and
you know we're able to take the ball
away today hey michael from a defensive
standpoint thinking about strata beach
how much did the experience of playing
the chiefs
in the past last year how did that
factor into how you prepared and played
well obviously you know watching those
games were huge you know to to watch the
first four games of the playing this
year was was big
but any time you go head to head it kind
of brings different elements you know
what they're gonna do to scheme against
your defense so
um you know obviously watching that was
the last couple games was big
um but we felt like you know those last
two games we could have played better
and you know even today we feel like we
could have played better but
um you know you'll be able to walk away
with a win
can you look at it as just the fifth
game but still also appreciate how big
this win can be for you guys going
forward with the head-to-head and all
the other stuff that goes with it yeah
you know i've been this long enough i
understand that type of stuff you know
head to head late late in the late in
the season um you know it's huge
but
it's week five uh you know we're not
throwing all our marbles into into this
game um we understand that
you know it's it's a good road win for
us um in any game any win is a is a huge
win and
you know we're thankful that we got that
today michael how did you guys handle
the weather tomorrow
and we're just hanging out
i mean we're just hanging out you know
eating some peanut butter and jellies
oranges uh listening to some music
you know talking about what we got to do
to get back out there and
just kicking it man we enjoy each
other's company so you know it was it
was crazy what time is
it uh
48. when did you guys know that this
game was going to be different than last
year
throughout the week of preparation i
mean
we believe in ourselves uh we believe in
you know and our teammates we believe in
our you know just the way we go about
things um
you know obviously last year left a bad
taste in our mouth so uh we wanted to
come back and and
you know
and play well today and uh
you know we had a great week of practice
coach put us in a position to make plays
mike had to pick six greg had a pick
just some big plays in the game that you
know saran's uh fumble on on the kickoff
just some big plays that we had today to
to keep us in the lead jordan doesn't
feel like does it feel like in some way
that you guys have cleared a hurdle
based on your history with this team
well i mean like micah said i mean it's
week five uh it's still early in the
season obviously it's a big road win for
us um
did we play
you know
that great you know there's still some
mistakes out there that we can learn
from um and like i said still early this
season
you know
still early
start of the season but you know he did
reference and i set it off the top of
the highlights that this was a rematch
of the afc championship game last year
jordan porter acknowledged that you know
there was a little bit of that right in
in their minds 100 percent what happened
last season yeah agreed i mean they knew
they had a they they viewed themselves
as a super bowl team so they knew they
had to go at some point and either beat
kansas city in their own field or
tonight and of course i think that takes
a lot of pressure off of them and gives
them confidence going forward i think
that's the big thing but those two guys
right there hyde employer man are they
phenomenal they're the keys to the
defense they ask a lot of them in
buffalo they get everybody organized
mcdermott and leslie frazier run a lot
of different defenses like we were
talking about a minute ago so you need
two smart safeties that make sure
everybody's on the same page all the
time and they're phenomenal they really
can do everything coverage hit tackle
they lead i love the intensity they
bring to the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports